big hello
and uh welcome everyone uh to the
session cmp103
this session is about how do you manage
large fleets of google cloud compute
engine vms
and i'm ravi chintalapuri a product
manager in google cloud
and today i'll walk you through a few
solutions
what we are building to address a lot of
our customer challenges what we have
heard from you all
when managing large fleets of compute
engine vms
so i'll start with the very high level
what are the different problems what we
have heard from you all
an aggregated way summarized way there
and then we'll talk about what are the
solutions
we are building to go address those
challenges
in that specifically i'll drill down on
patch management
configuration management i'll also give
you a background on
why we chose this and how we're going to
go progress and make a road map
going with demos deep dive and demos and
wrapping up with
roadmap i understand you'll be listening
to a lot of sessions
in google less next so there'll be a lot
of data
it's very hard to remember everything
but there's one key takeaway but
one thing i want you to remember from
this session that is this
gcp now provides automated patch
management service configuration
management service
across windows and linux across your
linux linux distros across your hybrid
environments
obviously we prioritize gcp first with
things to come up
in the near future with that
i'll get started so i said uh
i'll start with what are the top
challenges what we have heard from you
all
when managing your large vm fleet
then we'll talk about how are we
addressing that
the interest of time i'll talk about
only a few of them the first one if i
start with
as more and more customers starts
migrating their
applications building their applications
in gcp
they're often dealing with thousands of
applications ten thousands of vms
petabytes of storage so managing this
large infrastructure at scale
easily and effectively has become a big
burden
for our customers second thing is
most of our customers are used to some
management tools when managing their
on-prem uh tools
on from infrastructure so as they make
their journey to the cloud
they expect the cloud providers like gcp
to provide some native management tools
because either those existing tools are
not compatible
with the one that's running in the cloud
or they might be working with only
specific cloud
third big problem what we have seen is
mostly from a security standpoint
think of a scenarios where we had
wannacry meltdown spectre
where any of these vulnerabilities hit
the biggest thing on an it advanced mind
is is my environment compliant
how bad is that how can i bring it back
to the compliance state
are all my vms on it in a desired
configuration
which of them drifted why drifted how it
drifted a lot
so managing security at a scale is
another big problem
well these are just some of the problems
uh talking about what we have heard from
a lot of our customers the interest of
time i picked up the top thing what we
heard
so what did really do after adhering to
all these problems
so we started we're building a suite of
vm management tools
in that we prioritize patch and config
keeping security and compliance as the
top
view a top priority for us so over the
next 15
20 minutes i'll walk you through each of
the solutions and how we build it
and how can you use it or can you
observe it and with the demos
i'll start with patch management
patching servers it's not something new
many of our customers as you all know
we've been patching servers for years
and years
but still it is one of the top it
management problems
so we're really curious to know why it
was such a big pain so we started
talking to about 100 plus customers
across the globe across the industries
um average size was ranging from 500 to
20 000
showing that we've covered smbs and even
the enterprise thing there
and here's a quick summary first thing
is a patch tuesday comes you know which
happens on the second tuesday of every
month the biggest thing on iit admin's
mind especially the patch admin mind is
what's the state of my compliance how
compliant i am how bad i
am and this thing i want this report
across my environment across my
fleet whether i'm running windows or
linux or different linux distros i want
one report
unified across my environment so i can
see the state
second big thing what we have heard is
reliability of patches what does this
really mean
as i was talking to many of the
customers one thing is super clear
most of them are patching in a phased
roller so they always start with
their dev environment first if that goes
fine they go to staging then pre-prod to
prod
they do this because they're worried
that a particular patch
or a package might create some
incompatibility issues might break their
existing applications
so they're trying to hope to find any of
the issues throughout this phased
rollout
so that they'll find something and they
can fix it before applying to the next
environment
third big category what we have seen in
general orchestrated patching what does
this really mean
most of our admin said they spend nights
and weekends
only when they're doing patching
applications primarily when patching
applications
the reason for that is they have to do a
bunch of things before they have to have
two bunch of things
later for example before patching they
have to make sure everything is working
fine
the health checks are there the agents
are running users are hydrated load
balancer taken care there's enough space
right after patching is done they want
to make sure their applications are
running
they will do the health checks services
check and that's why make sure that they
always do it in the maintenance
windows like in the friday night
saturday night and they spend a lot of
time to making sure everything is up and
running
and there is a sequencing they want to
go automate these processes when
something goes
fine automatically roll out the next
environment when the dev environment
goes fine go to stage so automatically
roll out
something goes go wrong stop
other big thing is application aware
patching so as i said application is a
key thing for any company
and when they're patching an application
they really want to understand the
application architecture
so think of your patching an ntr
application you always want to go do a
back-end first
your database is first then back-end so
you do a right order and everything so
understanding the application
infrastructure having a knowledge of
that is super important
last thing is as i talked earlier
patching is not something new
customers have been patching for years
so there's a lot of existing tools
so anything we build has to make sure
that at least integrates or provides a
value on top of an existing patch
management tools
okay so after listening to all these
problems
and re-prioritizing with our like okay
we came up with a solution and where our
vision is like we want to go
help our customers patch any os anywhere
anywhere could be windows or linux they
could be running in gcp
on gcp but our priority is right now
running in gcp
we launched ga in april this year so
that's the general available you all can
go use it however the scope is at
gcp both we do windows and linux what's
a big value prop as a customer why
should i use this
so that just two main value props you
think about this one is like
i get a compliance reporting across my
environments i code windows and linux
and gcp
telling you what's bad how bad it is
that second thing is
automated patch deployment ability go
fix that problematic machines and bring
it back
to the compliance and i'm going to go
detail into each of this stuff there so
so let's start double clicking on what
is patch compliance
so as i said when patch tuesday comes or
any new packages get released from
ripple managers one of the key things
for
patch admin is give me a compliance
report across windows and linux so
with our thing you get a dashboard as
you can see on the screen you can get a
view of
which part of my environment is green
which part of my environment is red
which one is bad
along with additional data because when
i just show you a patch compliance is
not enough i want to know
what's causing me to read that right
what type of patches i'm missing how
many patches i'm missing
how long i've been missing so because
there's an action item for each of this
if i if i'm running a company and if i
see everything red that's a showstopper
to me i'm going to stop and go fix that
if everything is most of them is green
but some are yellow probably time for me
to take a weekend off and come back and
fix it around the next business day
so that's one big aspect getting the
compliance via your environment with a
detailed metadata
second big thing you want to call out is
we tried our best to leverage
native tools native configuration rather
than reintroducing a lot of neutrals
yes we do have our own agent which
actually does the job but we actually go
talk to the native windows agent called
windows update agent remove
when we are patching for villex we talk
to the native repositories like em
apt-get the repo managers and everything
and we leverage whatever configuration
you have whether you're talking to
microsoft update where you're talking to
wss where you're talking to repositories
the key thing is we're leveraging most
of the native tools and config where we
can
the last thing is on the supported
operating systems for windows we support
uh 2012 and above
and linux we do red hat and centos 678
versions
ubuntu 1618 and debian um in our
documentation there's a clear
supported operating systems link that
will be constantly updated when we add
new operating systems
so that's the first part as an admin i
get the state of my environment
getting which one is good which one is
bad but the next important thing for
them is
how do i bring it back to the green
state that's my desire to how do i bring
it back everything to green how do i
automate this process
so that i don't have to worry about
everything
and that's where the patch deployment
comes after you knowing the compliance
state
when you're patching machines or your
environment the four
important questions come to any patch
admin
first thing is what vmc should i patch
should i patch at my application level
should i patch at my project level gcp
project
or a zone level or a particular region
level so we provide you
all the flexible targeting options you
could choose to patch all web servers
because that's how you labeled it
or you could to patch all my dev
environment so you have all the flexible
filters you can choose how the way you
want which i'll be demoing
in few minutes when i go there second
big important question
as an admin will ask is what type of
patch is installed the first one is what
vms that's great second
what type of patches i want to install
should i install critical security or
others
because i said every company have
different sls that's what we've heard
uh windows is 30 days save for example
it next could be 60 days 90 days so
every company differs but on average
every company have different
slas to go patch so depends on the type
of patches you want to go select
uh you want to sell here you need an
option to select type of patches that's
the patch configuration i'm talking
about
a couple of key things to hit here patch
exclusion
and many times when you have a
particular patch
it might break some of your line of
business applications or there could be
some
incompatibility issues so you might want
to exclude certain patches because
you know that's going to break something
so there's an apache exclusion
capability where you can specify
a kb article or a wild card in linux
like star dot kernel if you
don't want to install kernel patches
there's a patch exclusion
similarly there is patch inclusion uh
think of a scenario where you got
a security patch and you want that to
roll out to your environment
immediately and you just put that patch
include only this patch and roll out to
all my environment so that's the patch
inclusion capabilities
so the first question was what vms to
patch second thing was what patches to
apply
third big question comes to customers is
like when should i patch
patching is not a one time thing i'll be
doing recurring i could be doing like
first day of the month last day of the
month the last friday of the month so we
provide all those flexible options you
can do
now you can do one time you can do a
recurring and you can choose different
dates times
weeks of the days and everything i'll go
a lot more details when i demo that the
last part of scheduling is the
maintenance window enforcement
almost 90 percent of our customers told
me that they'll patch only during a
maintenance window
as we see people do it typically in the
friday nights saturday nights
or on the weekends so they have a
maintenance window set and they want in
doing the patch deployment only during
that time
so in our uh product we can specify a
window saying that hey
start at nine o'clock in the night on a
friday but run for only for three hours
so we'll ensure that we run only that
three hours including the reboot
and we finish off whatever we're running
and we get out of the process so that
your app's up and up and running and
coming
so after the three questions what vms
what patches when should i patch
last important thing is controls what
additional controls i would need
i talked about a lot of patch
orchestration that's one of the top
concerns what
we have heard from our customers one of
the big thing is
ability to run three steps something
before patch
it could be health checks or disk space
and something to run
after the patch so in our ui you will be
able to select
certain prescripts this could be a
script which you upload to a google
style
cloud storage gcs pocket and we'll pull
it from there and we'll run it
and you can also condition it if the
script fails
the patch will deployment will stop so
you're not going to worry about like hey
am i master obstructing something there
the last part of the control was one of
the major feedback what we have heard
from beta when we released earlier this
year was
reboot control especially when you're
patching applications even though we do
a control reboot
as a patch admin i want to control my
reboot because that's my application
running
so we don't reboot if the user chooses
this selection it's a configuration
option
we will not reboot we will hand over the
control to the user so after the
patching is done
they can come and um control the reboot
as the needs so that's about the two
value props i've talked about one is
this
patch compliance state giving you the
state of environment how it is right now
snapshot
and the second thing is ability to go
fix that and automate this future you
don't have to do it those are the two
big value props of patch management
enough of me talking i really want to
show you how the product looks
in the ui so in this patch management
demo i'm going to walk you through
three things the first thing is how do
you on board and navigate and onboard
the patch management service
second thing is how do you get the patch
compliance and third things how do you
go do a patch deployment
basically go fixing those problematic
machines and bringing it back
to this compliance and you can automate
those process okay
how do i navigate so if i go to my
google console
go here go to compute engine and on the
bottom you can see
os patch management and this is the
screen what you will see
because you have not enabled the
services so and you can see what apis we
need what permissions and we
need and if you click on learn more it
talks about whole details about what is
this service how are we going to enable
how it works what's architecture what
does this agent do
what permissions all the details
once you enable the service and activate
the agent so the os config agent is part
of the most of the gc base images
base image packages except i think
ubuntu and suzy which we are looking to
add right now
but those things you have to do it uh
separately and we have a clear
instructions how do you go
install an agent and especially after if
you are using an older vms
you have to follow that instructions how
to go get this os configuration onto the
vms
so now enable the services and interest
of time i've already enabled it
i'll go to a project where i've already
enabled the service
so once you enable and activate we will
go scan
all your vms collect the data from all
the sources aggregate it and generate
this
reports let me walk you through each of
this stuff the first style
talks about all the vms i have to buy
operating systems looks like i've got 18
in this environment divided by different
operating systems
looks like my ubuntu is good it's not
missing any red so i don't have a
store stopper i can move on looks like
centos is bad i've got all the different
categories i'm missing i'm missing
critical
important other and few are up to date
similarly with windows
android head is also bad and if you want
to know more about what are these type
categories what does
each one mean if you click on this
particular link it will take you our
documentation let me just navigate there
so if you go to another documentation
page which talks about the whole
charts what you see there and explaining
what each one means and
how do we compute that going back to the
dashboard
now if i'm an admin i'm looking at this
i really want to know why is this bad
let me know which vms are having uh
problems and what sort of things we
already have this here
okay so you can also click on the vm
instances page as well here
so you see the same thing and here's
where you'll see the different vms what
you have
um part of that is let me pick up the
centos vm which is having and you can
see all the metadata here like what zone
it is what os distribution it's running
what os
version and it's saying that it's
missing critical updates when you go
click on that
that's where it shows that oh i'm
missing a lot of updates in this three
of them are critical
but other things are security and other
important something for me to take in
action
so in the upcoming releases we are
adding a lot of metadata
to show you a lot more data like cv
score what ripple manager can connect to
where do i get this patch it's a lot
more information in windows we are
adding
the kb links the msrt severity so you'll
get a lot more metadata in our upcoming
releases
so that completes the first part
where we have seen actually two parts
first we have shown about onboarding
you've seen how to get the patch
compliance in an environment state of
your environment
the third thing is as an admin i want to
go fix this problematic machines i want
to go create a deployment
so that installs the patches and brings
these vms back to the compliance state
so now i'm going to click on patch
deployment
so as i talked earlier in the slide
there are four questions which really
matters for patch admins when you're
doing a deployment
first is what vms to patch and we give
you a lot of flexibility to choose
different filtering mechanisms whether
you can
patch by a project a zone i'm talking
about a gcp project
zone region or you can use labels tags
name prefixes in this case i'm using
same labels called hey
environment dev all my dev machines i
want to go patch or i can choose to
patch
all vms okay
so we finished the first question of
what vms to patch second important
question is what patches i want to
install
because every customer will have
different slas for different patches
i've seen most of the customers have a
critical and security have to be done
within 30 days
if it is non-critical they have a little
bit more time 45 days there
so we give you all the flexibility so
you can choose what sort of patches you
want
like for example critical security
that's the only thing i care about
patch exclusion so this is what i was
talking about earlier if you know that a
particular
patch or kb this thing is going to break
your line of business application or
some incompatibility with a known thing
you can put that kb article you can put
multiple kb articles comma separated
we will exclude that when you are
installing the remaining patches there
and linux you can do like kernel updates
or you can do a wildcards you can use
any of those stuff there
the other hand what you call patch
inclusion you just want to install
selective updates microsoft released a
security patch or they've got a separate
package from linux vendor i want to
install that particular security package
on my fleet right now
or like in the as soon as possible so
you can include that particular kb
article
or uh the linux or whatever the
wildcards you are using to do that
similarly we do that same thing for
both windows and linux it's running m
red hat centers our app cipher you can
choose your own configuration and do
that
so that finishes the second question
what we had number of vms what type of
vms what patches
third question comes to patch admin
select when should i patch patching is
not something i do once it's a recurring
thing so i need give me all the
flexibilities to
do it now do it later
so for example if i choose end of the
month 12 a.m
or i want to be in a particular
recurring schedule like i want to do it
on
a specific day i want to do it on a
fourth
day fourth friday of the month or i can
do second saturday of the month second
tuesday of the month aligning with pat
tuesday so whatever
needs you have we provided flexible
recurring scheduling options so you can
choose whatever is right for you in my
case i'm going to choose schedule for
later doing end of the month other key
thing to talk about is duration
almost every customer confirmed that
they're going to install the patches
only during the maintenance window
typically happens on a friday night or
on a weekend there
so they want to make sure that the app
is down at that time no user is
connected to that
so here you can specify a maintenance
window like a duration
how long you want to install the patches
if you want to install the patches say
for like 120 minutes that's the only
time we will be installing the patches
um we'll including the reboot we'll take
care of that however we'll finish
whatever the
step is there will not start any new
step there so
the last thing which every batch admin
you will care about is
rebooting by default the system will
decide if the reboot is necessary based
on the metadata what i'm getting from
the package or packages
but some admins like i want to control
my reboot i'm especially i'm patching uh
my application i want to make sure that
this is actually working
i want to be in front of it and i want
to run some pre-steps and post up so we
give that options to choose
never so you can control it for now i'll
leave it as a default system
the next comes the pre and post scripts
this is when i was talking about a lot
of admins who want to run some things
before to make sure everything is
working fine
they want to run a lot of things after
make sure everything is working fine
there
okay how do you do that so you create
your uh script upload to your
gcs packet google cloud storage bucket
in our documentation we explain how do
you get that
script into the bucket now i can go look
at click on that it opens up a gcs
bucket and i can go
select hey i want to go do this my linux
prescript and normally you want to do
some postscript
you want to go select this and you want
to go build this
then you create your deployment so let
me show you what happens if you create a
deployment for the interest of time i've
already created a few things that's
where you go to schedule deployments
so once you create a deployment you can
actually see it here
right now we have an option only to
delete and recreate it if you want to
make any changes but in the near future
we'll be adding a capabilities where
you can edit you want to add more
machines you want to add in the
configuration you want to change the
date you will be able to do all the
changes
okay now i created it when the time
triggers the patch deployment runs and
it'll give you a detailed patch
status so let me show you one example
there so i've run some pad jobs last
week
uh later this week earlier this week and
it actually shows all completed
but there are some errors so let me pick
up a deployment which had a lot of vms
and it failed
so let me take this one which has got 16
vms and it failed
first it talks about a number of
instances it has uber level status
something errors occurred as an admin
here please take an action here look
into that
how long was the duration when it would
run it will give you all the details
if anything was left in between or it's
100 done
and what classifications you have
selected gives all the details now this
is the
result state if you look at in this
state some are successful in that 16
some failed because there's no agent
detected some of those configuration was
not running or something happened
some are inactive which means that
either machine could be offline or
something happen it's not running
so there could be other state and here
or the actual failed because of
incorrect function
for the patch but here's a clear logs if
you click on any of the logs you can
clearly see all the details about this
failure why it failed what time it
failed
typical verbose logs you get that stuff
and this is where you can go to
stackdriver logs to get a lot more
details
okay so that completes the three parts i
was talking about from patch
how do you navigate on onboard patch
management how do you get the compliance
state of your
environment and finally how do you
deploy patches
uh to install those patches so that you
bring that machines back into the
compliance
and set an automated recurring
deployment so every time
it takes care of that now let's talk
about
the next service it's on the
configuration management this is another
service what we prioritize based on our
customers need and also keeping
compliance in mind so let's start with
what are the top problems what we have
heard
with our customers when we spoke to them
the first thing is
when you go create your vm environment
you want that to be in a certain desired
state
like i want security agents i want
monitoring agents to collect all the
logs
or i want uh open certain firewalls
certain ports uh
certain accounts or you want to have
certain software
so that's first part you define your
desired configuration
the second big thing is how do i deploy
this to
entire environment at scale how do i
deploy this at scale
third big thing is maintaining it it's
not about deploying it one time that's
all good but
how do i ensure that this is maintaining
i don't want any drifts
whenever there is a drift as a user i
want to be notified
and obviously i want to auto fix it
later stage once i get a confidence but
at the minimum
i want to be notified if there is a
drift what drifted who caused drift what
happened why
how long it's been drifted so you need
to know all those details what we call a
compliance reporting
from a configuration standpoint the
other big thing device is like in a
unified way whether i'm bootstrapping
or installing a google first party
software or a third-party software i
need a unified way
the other big thing what we have heard
um from our customers
how do we integrate with existing ci cd
up tools for example most of our
customers use different third party uh
like ci cd tools like whether it's
jenkins
packard spencer any other day their own
tools there they use our tools to go
create the packages
and key things they want to take that
package and deploy into their
environment
at scale and maintain it so these are
some of the problems to store
so to solve some of the problems we
started creating configuration
management
where our value prop is going to be
three things define
deploy and maintain so what does it mean
will help you to define your
configuration file
second step will help you to deploy at
scale your entire environment
the same sort of filters what i talked
earlier in patch management where you
can do it at
a project level at a region level at a
zone level or a different instance level
what i talked about basically giving a
lot of flexible options so that you can
choose
how you want to deploy that i'm going to
give you a nice compliance dashboard
across windows and linux the same way
what we have done with the patch so
and with a lot of additional data as a
user you know which machines are in the
compliance which machines
went out of the compliance what caused
it go out of the compliance when it
actually drifted
to get a lot more details on that so let
me walk you through how the product
works
from a user standpoint when you have to
go start configuration management there
are two things you should think about
one is i'm
creating my desired conflict this is
think of that as simple yaml file where
you define
your desired conflict hey installs a
particular monitoring agent install
security agents have opened this
firewall
so you define all that stuff we call
that as a guest policy in our terms
because you're applying a policy to the
guest vm
second big big step is take that policy
and apply what we call assignment to the
bunch of vms
so let me double click on each of the
stuff
guest policy when i'm defining my policy
or the configuration
you might want to say what packages you
want to install all this part of the
guest policy
for example in this example i took an
example of i want to install a stack
driver and i want that to be always
installed my desired state is always to
be installed as you can see in the
screen
so in the same guest policy now you
define where do i get this package
binaries from
i want to install stackdriver that's
great but go pull it up from this
the url what i've given here
packages.cloud.com
third part of policy would be if a
particular software needs any
configuration for example in this case
is an msi
i want to do it in a certain way and if
you have other configuration like i want
to do like silent install
so whatever configuration you have you
can put it there so
think of like guest policy open up a
notepad or open up any of the editors
create ammo file put what package you
want to install
where you want to get the binaries from
put any configuration
and the next step is boom take that and
apply to bunch of vms
now let me walk you through how that
happens in uh
pantheon console which is google cloud
console so in this configuration
management demo
just like patch management i'll talk
about three things one is how do you
onboard
out of the configuration management how
do you use it the service
and next is how do you get this creating
a policy applying the policy i'll show
you some of the cloud commands
then assignment okay the first thing is
on boarding so if you have onboarded uh
the patch management service what i've
showed earlier
that will enable all our uh the os
config apis
so you're all taken care and you'll have
everything done you'll also have the
gcloud commands you can start using it
when we launched uh the config
management beta and the first half of
the year it's api only so we are
building the ui the user experience
there
so the api is already enabled but in a
scenario where
if you want to use only config
management so
go to uh same computer engine or you can
go to api services
and just type os config api
and you'll see a screen just like this
will be an enable button in this case
i've already enabled so showing disable
button there
so once you enable it um it's the same
api which
powers both patch management
configuration management and other
services so
we are building so think of this as a
common api layer where you can access
that
okay that's the first part of creating
the configuration part
second step as i talked about my slide
the first thing is about how do i create
my guest policy which is my desired
configuration there
so so this start with any editor
whatever you have and start drafting
your aml file
what package you want to install what
configuration you want where do you get
the repo manager there or you can take
any of
from our examples so if you go to our
configuration resource link and i've
added all of these things in the later
parts of the slide so you can actually
look at that stuff but
if you go to google compute engine and
say configuration management setting up
config you can see all those examples
here
in this we provide a lot of examples
like how to install a stack driver agent
um how do you install other things there
and so there's a lot of examples you can
see what steady you want how do you do
an assignment where you want to keep it
as a lot of examples then it talks about
how do you create a guest policy
so this is a simple gcloud command what
we use to go create a policy so that it
brings
into the system so for my demo in the
interest of time
i've already like created the policies
and everything and got to the system
so first thing i'll start with a simple
view of
show me all the policies i have my in my
environment so let me increase the size
a little bit so you can actually see
better so g cloud
sd card there's a beta because the oscar
configuration manager is beta then we
talk about os config
and guest policies list hit that i think
i've done two policies i should see both
the policies one is a strike driver
policy
another windows policy second thing is i
want to know what exactly is in that
stack driver policy so i want to say
again g cloud beta os config guest
policy i want to say describe
and all the examples all the examples g
cloud examples and everything are in our
documentation so you can find out all
the samples which the cloud to run when
and it would actually show the sample
in this case i'm installing a stack
driver agent if we go up it talks about
where am i pulling the packages from
i will talk about uh some labels here as
you can see so which means that any vm
just got a label called color is equal
to red that's where we'll apply this
vm so next time we create a new vm put a
label this
configuration will be automatically
applied and you can put some policy
assignments there okay
in the interest of time i took the
policy and applied to a few vm so let me
see how many vms i got applied to
so you want to see like guest policies
uh you want to see describe and you can
also want to know
what's been installed and everything
there so let me show that one as well
very quickly
and the other command for this is gcloud
command
and this actually saying same gcloud
compute instance os inventory list
instances
so instances which has got the stack
driver agent so you can actually see
that stuff
all instances what i have in that stuff
there so i've got two machines which
i've got
this particular stackdriver agent
installed
cool so that completes a configuration
management demo where we
talked about how do you onboard the
service how do you create the compliance
uh your desired configuration guest
policy how do you apply that on your
this thing and you can how can you
verify that stuff there
cool let me go back to the slides
so the key thing is about roadmap so as
i said we launched
ga of patch management in april the
first half of the year same time as we
launched beta configuration management
so rest of the year second half of 2020
we will be launching uh
multiple versions of os patch management
where we're doing incremental
updates improvements some of things
could be really simplifying that
onboarding experience
applying a lot of customer feedback and
getting a lot of feedback from our
customers thank you so much for that
really appreciate your feedback
and also adding a lot of compliance data
so making the whole uh experience very
smooth
and in the documentation when we launch
it we'll provide a clear details about
what's coming in each of the launches
will have a way more details on what's
coming in each of the stuff there as far
as configuration management we launched
the beta
in the first half of it and that's api
only as i talked earlier now we'll be
building ui
on top of it the user experience a lot
more other capabilities which we are
targeting uh configuration management
preview by close to the end of the year
okay that brings to another important
topic pricing this has been one of the
top most concerned
questions i have been asked from my
customers there so
let me retreat few key things here this
pricing what we're talking about is for
both
patch and configuration management so
both the services
there's no cost from now until end of
the year so you don't need to pay there
anything until end of the year starting
jan 2021
will be charging per node which is like
per vm per month
of course prorated an hourly rate key
thing is there's no cost for the first
100 vms
after the additional one say 101 vm if
the os
config agent is running and continuously
sending the data and doing something
that's where you will be charged you
will charge the rate of three cents per
hour
so if you keep this just for math
if you keep this running os agent
continuously 24 by 7
30 days you pay two dollars per node per
month for both config
and vm uh i put a link here that gives
you complete details in our
documentation about
what is os config agent running mean
what are things i can do i cannot do how
i can recharge
a lot more details on that okay
moving on so in this slide i've included
a lot of resources
so we're getting started with how to do
patch management what's our architecture
how does this thing works
and i put a links for detail how to
create a pad job how do you manage your
pad job
same thing with configuration management
policies how do you manage these
policies there
along with sdk links api links it's the
same thing what i showed you earlier
just that we have a full link to the
full page where you can see all the
details about the supported operating
systems how to get started and
everything
including some of our blog links i would
like to make one announcement
you must have already heard about active
assist which is a new
solution to reduce the cloud complexity
by providing some proactive and
intelligent features
and doesn't matter what you're running
compute storage
security billing cost so there are
features in every area
which helps you with some reducing how
to reduce the cloud complexities
in the below links you'll have a lot
more details than this
i'm happy to say patch and configuration
management are also part of
active assist okay moving on
key takeaway so i know i've covered a
lot of content with like demos and
everything and hard to remember
everything but if there is one thing the
key takeaway what you take out of this
session this is this
gcp now provides an automated patch and
configuration management tools
across your fleet across your windows
and linux across your linux distros
with that we'll wrap up thank you so
much for everyone for your time
today and going through the session and
especially thanks to all the customers
who have given a lot of product feedback
and make us help better the product the
way it is right now
i continue to request that please go
play with the product give us more and
more feedback to make it better
thank you